all right Anthony
uh would you grow up where are you from
originally
well I was uh born in Los Angeles but I
grew up outside of uh
Washington DC and Maryland
tell me about your childhood
it was a
it was actually very typical and
you know
it's what I view to be typical although
I think in Looking Back Now most would
say it was extremely austere a very cold
it's taken me a while to actually
understand that and internalize it most
families don't not display love or or
affection there was none growing up it
was it was very cold but I would say
typical I'd say both my parents were
good people but something in it
something about the repression sort of
this Catholic repression
that had been in both my parents growing
up uh forced me into developing sort of
an internal anger I think against the
world sort of a misunderstanding like I
like I was uh always having to hold
things in it was more of your parents
personal style more than their careers
or anything like that well it's
partially career well my mother was
staying home very controlling hovering
type my father was cold and distance so
there's that Dynamic I think has been
discussed a lot especially in
psychologists you know in Psychology is
having a certain influence but but I
definitely see that as being the case
for my family
my parents any abuse
um there are different type I think more
of a strangeness strange Dynamic type of
abuse the type of abuse that originates
from not uh you know not experiencing
the a feeling of being desired or wanted
you know I was always a black sheep
that's still abuse yeah I mean and it's
the thing is is I'm
I'm not sure what it is about me but
it's even now it's almost as if you know
this there's this atonement like like
I'm still being rejected by my parents
by in everywhere I go you know I walk
into a store get out of here and it's
and it's I'm thinking I don't look like
I'm going to steal anything but they're
right on right away they're they're like
get out of here you know same with my
parents 18 years old get out of here
everyone just says get out you know
that's I always I've always felt and uh
you know that's it contrasts with the
the fact that I've had achievements you
know I've you know I was uh in the top
10 best cellists in the state of
Virginia back in 2010 and uh you know
and things like that I I won a
competition
um writing a paper or a policy report
about uh security related issue uh
there's rather some in front of some
academics you're a good student as well
yes yes in front of academics and some
people who were high-ranking government
officials and uh you know and and and
all that and yet uh you know it what I
really want to do what I've always
wanted to do is live in the dirt you
know I've and I think and not really
wanted that but that's where I've always
ended up you know it's like I want to go
to the lowest places and uh and and
that's how I really and I'm stuck now
you know I'm stuck in those places why
do you think you're
attracted or interested and fascinated
with that I'm not sure where that comes
from I think it's uh
I think it just represents the ultimate
I mean in some sense it is the Rebellion
still that Rebellion against that
parental influence
um but I just feel like it's more
authentic I think today we're always
placed in in circumstances that are very
unnatural for human beings and I think
when I'm around people actually who are
really just even you just see the pure
greed in their eyes you know the the
things they just want and snatch and
grab it's like well you see something
there that's more palatable than this
repression this uh special etiquette we
develop for use in Social Circles you
know though I see something more
appealing in that Honesty than I do when
I when I uh there's a lot of secrecy in
the as you climb these ladder right
right well I mean and and if you're in
you know it's like me I've seen all
these different echelons of society in
the higher echelons I see so much as
being staged you know it is truly like
an act it's it's these uh it's these
they're just maneuvering and but really
they have the same greed in their eyes
as a as a dope fiend you know does just
looking it's trying to snatch the next
hit it's the same it's the same concept
it just manifests in a more legitimate
way I think down here what kind of kid
were you in high school
um I was a I've always been a misfit you
know I I was shy and uh I've always been
someone who you know I'll have friends
in every group but never never fit into
one you know there always would be
something that would hold me back from
Full membership in any one group which
is kind of interesting so After High
School you did what After High School I
just I went immediately to selling drugs
um in in a state where I lived uh it led
to a lot uh worse penalties
um an ounce of marijuana got me over
like got me a month in jail sentence
um and uh and and after you know and
basically just I'd
I wandered and threw everything to the
wind I worked jobs
but uh and I did I went to treatment
every now and then but it all felt
always forced to me it always feels like
someone's trying to get something out of
you
um get some like
that's that's what's always frustrating
me I guess is this this lack of feeling
like there was really authentic help
that isn't some guy trying to blow up
his uh his array of uh Narcotics
Anonymous fans or uh or or or feel like
he's a a father figure to some Protege
you know that that he's trying to raise
it's all it's it's just it's it's like
you become disillusioned to that stuff
you know the more you're exposed to
which is why I've just been pushed
further and further and further away
from traditional recovery type things
you know did you ever have dreams of
doing something with your life yes and
uh you know I've wanted to you know I
was hugely aspiring to go into the
military for years that was uh since
2017 I just had been obsessed or
actually before that obsessed to joined
in the military I thought it would fit
my personality
um and I had you know I I S I speak
fluent nearly fluent Russian
um and uh you know I'd studied Arabic
and I'd uh I'd done all these different
things and that was that was what I
wanted to do but uh you know as always
the past and and my my behaviors you
know they came together in such a
perfect storm to prevent that dream and
uh you know numerous uh hospitalizations
things like that prevent me from being
able to pursue that path did your dress
did your drug sales turn into drug use
oh yes drug use is my number one
problem I mean that is that's why I'm
here I'm you know I went from someone
who was you know a classically trained
cellist
a great students Straight A's I just
graduated college you know a year ago
but throughout that whole entire time
heavy hardcore drug use
now I'm 29.
and you went through college using yes
yes crack cocaine primarily
um methamphetamine
um all of it what is your drug currently
currently it's of course it's Fentanyl
and now I mean now I I spend hours
walking down the streets with a downward
facing glare trying to determine whether
there's anything invaluables that I can
take because I think at this point
something you know that the shoplifting
which was great when I was younger has
been come impossible I can't make money
that way anymore because they seem it's
like I walk in there immediately like I
said get out of here you know I think it
and I I think maybe I've lost become out
of touch how to testable my outward
appearances you know so
and you still talk with your parents no
no I don't talk with my parents uh I I
did have some support from a family
member who is my grandmother but she
passed away and she was all I had left
she really that's the way and that's why
I think now I when she died I left uh
you know I I was my my aunts promptly
said get out you were done and so I I
left and moved here basically I just now
I'm a street dweller so how long you
been in L.A
um I've been in L.A I guess I've lived
in this area for the past
seven or so years I think it's been yeah
about seven years but um I
I have been on skid roasts living
outside for the last
eight to nine months what's it like
being a white boy on a skid row uh you
know it's I think the more the more that
people are honest with who they are and
don't become Pretenders I think the
better they do in terms of dealing with
others like like I just act like myself
and I finally get along with most people
I think definitely sometimes I'm taking
advantage of more than most because I
tend to be I tend to still have sort of
this generous side
um and that that becomes a problem
there's a there's an incredibly
fascinating economy here you know of how
people are dealt with
um and how people behave how they're in
their money
um it's fascinating it truly is I think
one of the reasons people like you are
fascinated with it as well
um for me uh it's amazing like my way to
get through is a mixture of all these
different things you know just uh like
we're doing various favors uh selling
objects you know selling things I find
on the street that end up being worth
money
um you know it's it's just fascinating
but I've done okay I don't have enemies
uh who who are out to get me you know I
don't have as far as being white it's
been a disadvantage but it hasn't been
the whole entirely uh you know like a a
defining factor of my being here what's
the most uh
distasteful thing you've had to do for
money
um distasteful thing or degrading or
whatever
um
well I haven't
I haven't
um
I think so there was a there was a time
like I was not in a vehicle with someone
who was offering it to get me food
and the person end up ended up driving
really far and I was so tired I hadn't
noticed and opened my eyes I realized oh
God we're nearly out of we're way out of
skid row like we're in we're in
practically you know on the other side
of town and the person uh pulled over
into an abandoned parking lot and wanted
me to you know want to meet and started
molesting me basically and I I just I
the thing was is I realized the problem
I was no it was middle of night and
there was no way I was getting back to
Skid Row unless this guy was driving me
back so I I didn't I just sort of sat
there and just kind of let him do his
thing but I refused to let him touch me
and uh and finally he he did drive me
back here but but that put up a lot of
tests for my patients you know just
being treated like that yeah you know
treated like like a commodity or treated
treated that way is hard but I've I've
tried really hard to you know stay in a
certain to a certain level you know what
I mean try and stay at a certain level
to avoid doing certain things you know
who's Skid Row
the
the epitome of of that dirt that you're
looking for it's it's and that's the
thing is it and when you say it that way
it sounds almost as if it's like thrill
seeking like a like it's an experiment
and you know it really isn't it's my
life now you know like and that's
something that's it I have to accept
it's like it's this is who I am now you
know as I am the person living here and
I guess where I was leading was so the
way that your family
treated you
with the lack of
kindness and love
does that lead you eventually to believe
you deserve something as low as this
Maybe
did you ever feel loved I don't feel
that I I don't feel that any you know
that's the thing is
no of course of course I haven't I felt
loved by my grandmother uh she she
enabled me to to feel like a diff to be
a different person I mean that was
someone who who you know like I said you
know I have the college you read there
was a point in time when things looked
for me looked like I was going to have a
legitimate job you know where it looked
like I was going to be someone who was
successful in life I was sure
um when she died and you know it just
was like there was nothing left you know
I mean no one else to do it for and uh
and it was just me and the drugs and
that's all it's been you know since then
but the drugs were there before the
drugs were there during it always was
the drugs the drugs of what I've chosen
you know and uh and that's it you know
and and then people have all these
different routes they offer as a way of
being positivity like uh their way out
it's like what do I want though what do
you have to offer that I want not really
anything you don't have what I want you
know I don't I don't know what it is
exactly but a feeling of belonging you
know someone like me is so susceptible
to membership in a cult or something
like that it's like I I've hit that
personality type I realized you know but
it's tough you know because there's
nothing I want you know I just want to
be here I just want to be around these
people I just want to do these drugs I
don't really know you know it's easy
easy to achieve it's easy to achieve
it's true you don't need a diploma yeah
yeah I wish there was more you know
maybe it sounds maybe like depression or
something but I wish there was more our
society you'd think had to offer people
you know in terms of uh
creating their own their existence
something to motivate them yeah because
something to love yeah exactly something
to care about be passionate about truly
put yourself out there for it because a
person gets lost in drifts right if they
don't have it right that's why so many
people end up Yanks you know they're
looking for that thing they can be they
can put their loving side towards in a
way their loyalty you know some people
and their other and then they're the
Predators who don't have that side at
all and they're just looking to
manipulate those people and uh it's a
lot of what I've seen has just been that
Darkness it's that predatory nature in
people the desire to take from you and
and uh my my awareness as it happens
that I'm being taken advantage of but
yet I still hope some part of me still
hopes that maybe they're authentic you
know maybe they truly actually do care
you know uh every day something like
that someone disappoints me in that way
how long you been on the streets I've
been well I've been out on the streets
for I think about since uh the exact
time would have been August of last year
so now it's coming up on March
so
[Music]
yeah I guess about six seven months yeah
and how long you've been using drugs
I've been using drugs since I was 15.
is it are you sliding backwards downward
I mean I use it's my only focus and it's
my only purpose in life
that's that's the thing that I have that
I admit you know it's my own it's the
only thing I want to do
it's all there is
um I see no other I have no other Focus
whatsoever I've completely devoted
myself to that
and uh and it's just with rage and
anyone it's like even people who try and
help me I feel rage towards them you
know it's like why are you why you care
you know get away from me so you feel
like you don't deserve that
help or encouragement or care
that that it's on it's uncalled for
where were they before you know when
when things did matter to me where were
they then yeah
now they're not there so
so you've been in love before
yeah
I I did uh she it was a very unstable
relationship but I think it was love
um but she you know we I use drugs and
she uh you know she cheated on me she
had her own advice and that in that
sense of being trying to manipulate
emotionally
um but she's yeah she's gone now and uh
I did have I did you know I always will
think back on the loves my life as being
those like unrequited High School loves
you know because they're always pure
they'll never be damaged by actual
relationships behaviors yeah anything
like that those will always be something
like treasure but
how did you first get introduced to
drugs
um just offered to me uh in general in
high school you know I started
that's the thing you know it's like I
started just like anyone else would all
the conventional roads conventional
childhood conventional marijuana use
gets an Adderall pill uh gets a drink
you know that kind of stuff all
conventional all normal
um it took a lot
of time for me to finally have just
been willing to just throw it all away
but I did
I did it I threw it all away
and that's that's why I'm I'm different
than some people here in that they
they never had opportunities you know I
had those opportunities and
um you know I squandered them
and uh and and yet I don't feel like I
could have done anything else you know
you know based on the circumstances
you know I don't feel like I would have
done anything else
and um but there are people I've and a
lot of people I met and I admire them
um they never had those opportunities at
all they've had much worse
uh times growing up mine was very
asymmetrical my my childhood story very
asymmetrical uh unusual you know having
been in a high income Community
um been around people who were driving
had to reverse cars before they even had
their learner's permit
um that money the wealth the parents
working High to your jobs at Major
multinational corporations
um and uh and me you know I just I just
always floated as a Wallflower and uh
and it was the same there as it is now
just from the outside looking in but the
one thing I know is that I don't want to
give up you know like is my ability to
choose who I become
um you know even if it is the Stark path
you know it's
it's it's tough to feel it's tough to
feel emotion when you've gone through a
certain number of things you know you've
gone through enough and you no longer
feel sentimental attachment and it's
just like what I would never wish is for
this to happen to other people you know
that's really I guess the only thing is
like I wouldn't want other people to
have this to have this life because I
wouldn't curse anyone with it in my
worst ceremony
dear friends I
is always the same it's like the friends
I've had since I was a child do we talk
anymore are we on good terms not really
you know but but uh but like I'll always
consider them my friends you know my
best friends but as far as friends out
here
they're not really genuine friendships
you can't be um and I want the
legitimate friendships you know and I've
tried
um most of the time like when I've
gotten real close to having legitimate
friend they've disappeared
um one of my friends recently just
disappeared out here who I really cared
about
um another guy disappeared when I just
met him I thought he seemed like a
really authentic legitimate person
another guy turned out to be a liar in a
poser you know and uh and it's just like
all these different things you know
they'll they'll be fake lie to you uh
manipulate you and uh
it's like there's always somebody behind
the curtain trying to trying to take
advantage of you and I feel like almost
I'm the only person here who's who's uh
just like wondering what's going on you
know like where's the where's the
authenticity where the real people
struggling against the tide like I am
trying to swim to stay afloat you know
so
with the snake bit down here
it's a snake pit down here it is it
truly is it's a miracle I've been live
I've overdosed three times uh to cold
dead type overdose where my heart
stopped had to be defibrillated three
times in a week
so my nickname was for a time was OD
D is that when you first started trying
fentanyl I know it was about it was a
couple weeks into fentanyl yeah and uh
yeah that's what happened overdose three
times in a week
um
just uh
just died basically died legally I guess
or technically in front of the in front
of the exchange they defibrillated me
and I came back
um two other times I had to be narcaned
with over two Narcan three Narcan I
think was a number of times they did it
I just didn't care you know I was
actually pissed every time that they
that they will I was angry with them I
said why why'd you do this to me now I
have to go through this terrible
precipitated withdrawal effect
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
you know and that's the thing that what
I describe myself as a self-structive no
um it just ends up looking that way
some sounding that way
um it ends up you're living on the
streets you're trying to kill yourself
yeah yeah yeah
all this stuff and that's what it must
be but no I wouldn't describe myself as
selfish circuit I think I'm just being
self-destructive
are you lonely
I'm the loneliest person in the world
completely lonely I uh but it's it's
just to be expected now you know but
like the other day I was stuck
I got stuck I'd been led by this guy all
the way up through town and this
imaginary friendship you know thing and
and he disappeared and all right so I'm
leaving anyway I was I was at 9th Street
and I was trying to walk back down to
eight and I finally finally got to
eighth after I tried all three other
streets there was eighth I said great so
next one's got to be seventh the next
one I go to is ninth and then I walked
back and there's seven to seventh
finally but then I walked back and
there's ninth again and seventh ninth
and oh here's flower but they're ninth
it's just seven eight nine ten I
couldn't get out of there and I walked
in there in that Circle for three hours
and I literally was screaming at the top
of my lungs to anyone who listen where
how do I get out of this place how do I
it was like a joke like a movie how do I
get out of here help let me out and I
was screaming at the top of my lungs and
absolutely no one even acknowledged me
even looked at me I was freak it was the
same freak when I was a kid I'd say Mom
Dad look at that guy it's like that's
the guy I am now you know how'd I end up
like that [__] I don't know
so but uh that's what I was doing and
screaming to myself how do I get out you
know it's just in the hell you know that
I've witnessed down here the
this this uh circus-like impossibilities
you know the the horror show you know it
goes on and on and on forever it never
stops just the hell it's like this tape
you can't get to stop playing as you
walk down it's just over it's it Scrolls
at you like a movie all the horror and
the people and the schizophrenics
talking to themselves and then you feel
like you're and then you realize you're
doing the same thing you're saying
they're repeating some nonsensical
phrase over and over again or Screaming
how do I get out of here at the top of
your lungs on a on a pretty domesticated
Street do you sleep
uh yeah I I mean I slept last night you
did where did you sleep uh well if I
I was lucky I got I managed to just uh
just a week ago to get into a shelter so
but the thing was even during the
rainstorm I was I was outside I didn't
want to go back into the shelter I felt
suffocated but last night I was so
exhausted finally I had to go into the
warmth and I got I got some sleep so but
a lot of monsters out shelter
and then you would sleep where a Wine
Guard no but but when you were on the
street you would sleep where in a town
I'd actually just honestly I would fall
asleep wherever I sat down yeah on the
sidewalk I actually had my foot leg run
over by a car I fell asleep on on the
street with half of my leg in the street
they're half out and when I woke I woke
up to the most excruciating pain it ever
felt in my life and the lady who was uh
the guy who woken up was saying oh God I
just ran over man no idea and this guy
who's a resident said oh he was just on
heroin you better make sure that uh you
better make sure you uh you tell them
that that he's gonna want your money and
all this stuff and I was like God like
can someone call it [__] ambulance
please like my leg just got run over and
since then I've had limited use to my
right leg and uh I felt I had a numb
foot I can't really feel my foot like
the padding of it it feels like I'm
always wearing a pad or something like
that it's a snub and uh and you know the
guy was saying you better make sure you
you get a report here so you know this
guy's on drugs and that's why this
happened
I don't have any anymore
I think I've been through everything
that a person can go through to the
point where they don't have fears I
think mainly is just unwanted unwanted
attention or you know just that unwanted
people coming up to me saying things to
me is like that's really my the worst
thing people can do to me now is I just
want to be left alone you know quiet you
think there's a better chance of you
getting clean or dying here in the
street I've almost committed to death
here
I mean I wish I weren't true
you know it's I wish it weren't true I
wish it weren't so morbid it's it's just
that I don't I don't
have
you know even with someone having like
the brain that I have or skills that
I've had I just don't have really
anything that I want you know what I
mean like give me uh give me four walls
in the bed and uh you know it's like
it's nice books to read it's like what
else do I want you know I mean like yeah
I don't know I just I
I want the drugs and I want I want to be
left alone yeah
that's what it comes down to
I want a legitimate job you know I'd
like to be able to just sweep it up the
streets and something like that you know
just doing whatever I have to do during
legitimate money because clearly I've
been canceled out of a criminal capacity
to make money that way but being
prevented from that but uh but yeah you
know I just want a legitimate job make
enough money to sustain myself you know
do you have siblings
uh no no
so
yeah
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
just that
the most important lesson
[Applause]
family keep your family close
which you failed to do
or your family has failed to do
I'd say that is really it keep your key
to people that matter to you close
no hold on don't lose them
you can cut the camera off yeah thanks
thank you very much